Valentine's Day is tomorrow love is
definitely in the air Amazon books
editorial director Sarah gellman is here
with her top picks to celebrate all
types of Love look at what kind of music
they gave you for that I love it before
we start we should mention that three of
the books we're going to talk about are
published by Simon Schuster which like
cbs's division of Paramount Global first
up uh one of those books is from author
and life coach Jay Shetty who has a book
called Eight rules of love yes I love
this if you're someone who likes to work
on your relationship I think we all need
to work on ours then read eight rules of
Love This is highly anticipated so Jay
Shetty has a top-ranked podcast millions
of followers on social media yeah Billy
he's been here sitting right where you
were sitting he's fantastic I feel more
peaceful already yeah uh he has billions
of views on YouTube and in this book he
actually takes his learnings from his
time as a monk adds in some modern
science and applies it all to
relationships and one thing a very
important thing to walk away with is
that until you love yourself you can not
commit to someone else and I love this
book has a little something for everyone
it has sort of spiritual teachings he
weaves in his own story including a very
disastrous proposal story there's really
provocative chapters like your partner
is your Guru and there are activities
too that you can work on to kind of make
yourself better in love that's cool if
you have no partner and you're into
being single single uh there's a book
here for you as well right yes the
Lonely Hunter on May lutkin this is part
number that just sounds sad yeah
actually no no the lonely
love is broken this is lonely in the
title I thought it was about pride and
being single it is it's about all of
that yeah so it's a memoir and cultural
exploration so the author Ami lucken was
at a dinner party and her friends say
like hey who are you dating and she said
I think I might be alone forever and
they're all like Oh no you're gonna find
someone and it makes her think about why
there's so much pressure to couple up
how we value couples over single people
and I love this part whether being alone
is the same as being lonely they're not
the same they're not the same good
question no they're definitely nothing
you should be lonely in a relationship
too exactly right next you have a book
for rom-com lovers number one I'm sort
of thrown by the book thing because I
would like to be taken out to dinner or
you know something fun so to me I don't
necessarily think of Valentine's days as
books oh you say I know
the books will always love you they will
keep you warm at night they'll never
disappoint you okay if you give someone
a book for Valentine's Day and you would
write a very sweet note on the inside
that's why that book matters that's nice
yeah it's like a book of love poetry
would be nice yeah but you said book
this is a romantic comedy book and I
feel like what's comedy books it's the
second you're single it's keraton
kanamachi excuse me and this is a book
about a writer a freelance writer who
after a string of disastrous
relationships decides that she's going
to give up on love and on men for the
month of February and she's going to
write about it for work she has a
hashtag go solo challenge that she
writes about but of course romantic
comedy Fate has other ideas and she
reconnects with a childhood friend is
this a true story no it's a novel
because it's fun it is laugh out loud
funny Last Story a sweet story about a
prickly Cactus yes so this is a
children's book but I also love it if
you have kind of a sweet and sour
partner this is good for them too nobody
hugs a cactus by Carter Goodrich this is
a favorite in my house it's a picture
book ages two to seven but really for
anyone he's a prickly Cactus and he
shouts things like get off my lawn and
then one day he decides he's lonely and
he wants a hug so I won't give away the
ending but I will say that the moral of
the story is that there's a lid for
every pot out there I I actually do
believe that it's so sweet even if it's
a sweet and sour partner I think yeah
sometimes they're a little prickly but
yes even cactuses need hugs there's a
gentlemen Happy Valentine's Day